bonjour Monsieur Christophe perra
directeur du service d'enquête
judiciaire des finances du ministère de
l'économie des finances et de la
souverineté industrielle et numérique
merci de votre présence à cette audition
devant notre commission d'enquête sur
l'impact du narcotrafic en France les
mesures à prendre pour y
remédier je vais vous laisser présenter
les personnes qui vous accompagnent et
puis après il y aura une obligation
formelle de prestation de serment et
puis on attaquera l'audition
ensuite
merci monsieur le Président donc
Christophe Perot le directeur du sejf je
suis accompagné de Monsieur Philippi qui
est un de mes deux directeurs adjoints
dans qui est plus spécialement consacré
à la branche douane du service et à ma
droite Madame Valérie Man qui est chef
du pôle investigation du service merci
alors je rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête serait
pass possible des PE prévu aux articles
334-1 434-13
434-1 34-1 du code pénal et je vais
inviter chacune et chacun d'entre vous
qui allit prendre la parole à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité à lever la main droite et à
dire je le
jure je jure je jure merci alors je vous
propose pour le bon déroulement de de
cette audition que vous commenciez par
un petit propos liminire ensuite notre
rapporteur Étienne blanc ouvrira le le
le bal des questions relayé par mes
collègues sénatrices et sénateurs de la
commission d'enquête je vous en prie je
vous remercie monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur madame
messieurs donc ainsi que j'indiqué je
suis le patron le directeur du sejf
anciennement sndj alors dit comme ça ça
peut-être pas évoquer grandchose pour
vous mais sndj c'est le service national
de la douane judiciaire qui a été créé
il y a une vingtaine
d'années à l'origine parce que les
douaniers voulaient aller plus loin dans
leurs enquêtes et ils trouvaient que les
moyens qui étaient à louer les moyens
procéduraux qui était alloué à la Douine
classique ne leur permettait pas d'aller
plus loin dans les trafics et dans
l'identification des traficants en
réalité c'est ce qui a justifié qu'en 99
on crée des officiers de douane
judiciaire qui en 2002 ont été regroupés
dans un service le service de national
de la douane judiciaire qui a cette
particularité d'être dirigé par un
magistrat c'est le seul service de
police judiciaire à compétence nationale
dirigé par un magistrat de l'ordre
judiciaire c'est la loi c'est le code de
procédure pénale qui le prévoit et donc
vous l'avez deviné je suis
magistrat et intérieurement j'ai été J
inststruction je me suis consacré
essentiellement à la lutte contre la
criminalité organisée et notamment à
Marseille où j'étais le patron de la GES
enfin des Ju instruction GES de
Marseille et j'ai été aussi à Paris
avant de venir au sndjjf j'ai été
procureur adjint avec Monsieur min c'est
Monsieur j'étais en charge de la
criminalité organisée et on a créé
ensemble la junalco donc vous avez
peut-être entendu parler donc qu'on a
auditionné la semaine dernière voilà
donc au-delà de de la de de ce que je
pourrais vous dire est-ce qualité de
patron du SJF j'ai cette expérience de
lutte contre la crmit organisé à la fois
comme je instruction à la GIR de
Marseille ou comme procureur adjoint à
Paris en charge de la la GES et de la
junalco pour vous donner mon sentiment
sur la lutte contre narcotrafic tel
qu'il est organisé et tel que N on nous
on la met en place en tout cas au sejf
donc sejf service d'enquête judiciaire
des Finances depuis
2019 c'estàd que depuis 2019 aux
officiers de Douin judiciirees qui ont
des compétences tout à fait
particulières on a ajouté
une compétence fiscale la présence qui
qui se traduit par la présence au sein
du service d'officiers fiscaux
judiciaaires qui travaille sur les
présomptions de fraude fiscale complexe
en fait la démarche qui préside qui a
préside la création de ce service c'est
qu'il différencie des autres services de
plus judiciaire qui soit gendarme
gendarm de police c'est que là on prend
des agents qui sont compétents sur la
fraude historiquement
professionnellement qui sont issus
d'administration qui travaillent sur les
flux et sur les irrégularités de flux
qui soit financiers ou de marchandise à
qui l'on donne l' donne c'est un bien
grand mot parce qu'en réalité on les
forme et on les forme à interne de
services pendant 6 mois conforme à la
procédure pénale et au droit pénal pour
devenir des enquêteurs judiciaires et
une fois qu'ils ont rejoint le service
ils ne travaillent qu'avec l'aide du
code de procédure pénale et sous
l'autorité exclusive des magistrats
c'est-à-dire que je suis euh
administrativement rattaché au directeur
général des douanes et et à à la
directrice générale des douanes et au
directeur général des finances publiques
mais en réalité je ne travaille que pour
les magistrats je ne rend compte qu'au
magistrat qui me saisissent en flagrance
ou en préliminaire ou sur commission
rogatoire donc concrètement sur les
procureurs ou les jeuxinstruction nos
partenaires privilégiés nos employeurs
privilégiés sont les juridictions
spécialisées JIRS junalco et parquet
national financier avec qui nous
travaillons beaucoup nous avons à la
différence aussi des autres services
d'enquête à compétence nationale que
sont les offices si on doit nous
comparer à quelque chose ce sont les
offices à la différence des offices nous
les odj et les ofj qui composent ce
service n'ont que des compétences
d'attribution prévu par la loi c'estàd
que on peut pas travailler sous sur
n'importe quelle infraction nous ne
pouvons travailler nous ne pouvons être
valablement saisis que sur les
infractions qui sont Lim limitativement
énumérux aux articles 281 et 282 du code
de procure pénage je fais cours les
infractions douignères les escroqueries
TVA le blanchiment pour parler des plus
grosses infractions s'agissant des
officiers de doin judiciaire et soit du
côté des officiers fiscaux-judiciaires
présemption de fraudes fiscal complexe
blanchiment de ces présemptions et
depuis la loi de finance 2024
escroquerie TVA et depuis la loi douan
2023 du 18 juillet 2023 les escroqueries
aux finances publiques compétences qu'on
partage maintenant au DJ ou FJ est-cocé
aux finances publques d'une manière
générique ce qui justifie d'ailleurs que
nous soyons en en pleine mutation
puisque dans le cadre du Plan fraude
porté la lutte du plan de lutte contre
la fraude porté par Monsieur hatal et
poursuivi par son successeur nous sommes
en pleine transformation de sejf en
nonaf office
national de lutte contre les fraudes aux
finances publiques voilà c'est ce qui
correspond d'ailleurs aux priorités
c'estàut dire qu'on va exercer un chef
de fila comme le font comme le faitofast
en matière de stup ou d'autres offices
en d'autres matières sur ces sur ces
matières que les fraudes que sont les
fraudes aux finances publiques c'est un
service qui compte 300
euh 21 agents euh répartis sur je sais
pas si c'est 21 mais c'est 21 réparti
sur le territoire national en ce sens
que nous avons 10 unités euh 10 unités
qui dépendent directement du du siège à
savoir que les magistrats lorsqu'ils
nous saisissent lorsqu'ils saisissent le
service ils me saisissent moi excalité
donc le directeur du sejf à à charge
pour moi de répartir les enquêtes au
sein des 10 unités qui sont implantées
territorialement sur euh selon une
logique qui euh n'en est pas comme
d'habitude qui ne correspond à rien euh
ça ne rejoint ni les régions
administratives évidemment ni les cours
d'appel ni les geirs ça aurait été trop
simple c'est euh donc voilà comme
d'habitude c'est plutôt la douane qui
avait des implantations géographiques et
et qui a plus pu caser ses douiniers
dans ses bureaux à la création du
service voilà ce qui a présidé au choix
donc grossièrement quand même on était à
Lille mais à mes à Lyon à Marseille à
Toulouse à Bordeaux à Nantes et et à
Paris évidemment avec une unité
seulement fiscale à Paris pour l'instant
mais j'en parlerai peut-être si vous
vous voulez le développement du service
va nous amener à à créer un groupe à
Marseille également de de fiscau et une
unité outreem basée à à la martique à
fort- de- France et deux trois petites
antennes Perpignan en matière de
stupéfiant c'est pas anodin euh à Nice
ainsi qu'àjon ça c'est le fruit de
l'histoire de la douane
aussi voilà j'ai j'espère ne pas avoir
été trop long c'est présentation du
service très clair Étienne bland notre
rapporteur très bien et merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Directeur dans un une
interview et au journal Le Point vous
aviez parlé d'aubertvillier
et et vous aviez indiqué à
l'époque parlant des systèmes de
blanchiment ils fournissent des produits
clés en main avec le paiement d'une
commission assez raisonnable et
blanchissent pour toutes les activités
illégales stupéfiant contrefaçon
importexort fraude à la TVA est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer les
mécaniques qui sont mises en place et ce
que vous avez fait depuis pour lutter
contre ce système bien identifié à
aubervillier euh h je me mermettrai si
si vous m'autorisez à à à à à rebobiner
la la le le le la pellicule du film pour
vous dire que lorsque j'étais au parquet
de Paris la criminalité qu'on appelle
chinoise pour être tout à fait clair
euh était un phénomène dénoncé par tous
les services mais sur lesquels personne
ne pouvait dire des choses synthétiques
et en tout cas ça ne se traduisait
absolument par aucune action réelle
menée sur cette problématique que tout
le monde décrivait comme euh à fort
enjeu j'avais réuni tous les services à
l'époque donc estce qu' était le
procureur adjoint j'avais demandé à tous
les services d'enquête de venir et de me
dire ce qu'ils faisaent les uns et les
autres et queles information et partager
on voyait qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'informations prisisolément mais qu'il
n'y avait pas véritablement de stratégie
mené en commun sur cette problématique
donc ça allait de l'OLAF au service de
2e DPJ et enfin l' cl enfin tout le
monde y avait tout le monde avait avait
son histoire à raconter sur le
blanchiment et sur au-delà de ça et la
douane bien évidemment qui connaît très
très bien ce phénomène mais il n y a pas
il y avait pas de stratégie commune je
suis pas certain qu'on ait beaucoup
progressé sur ce sujet aujourd'hui ce
qu'on connaît et que chacun connaît en
tout cas ceux qui s'intéressent à ces
phénomènes c'est que on a d'abord le
Sifa c'est d'abord un problème
d'importation en minéoration de valeur
ou ou déclaration mensongère sur
l'origine des produits qui sont importés
dans des ports en fraude des
droits à l'importation de la TVA euh
comp d voulez mais qui qui amène à à ce
qu'il y ait vous savez c'est le régime
fameuse fraude au régime 42 ça arrive au
port du Piret on déclare un container à
une valeur 10 en réalité il y a 100 dans
dans le
container le container n'est pas
contrôlé et les droits TVA ne sont pas
acquittés sur le port d'entrée de
l'Union européenne droit TVA sont
acquittés dans le pays de destination or
il se trouve que beaucoup de ces
containers se perdent sur le chemin et
les siétés qui sont soi-disant à
l'origine de l'importation sont des
sociétés totalement fictifes fantoche ou
qui disparaissent très vite lorsqu'on
entreprend des contrôlés et les
containur se perdent et se perdent par
pour tout le monde évidemment et
beaucoup de ces marchandises se
retrouvent au Sifa d'aubertvillier où là
elles sont redistribué et elles
nourrissent toute l'économie grise noire
qu'on connaît sur le territoire national
et partout en Europe générant une
économie parallèle fort destructrice
pour notre économie nationale et pour
ceux qui
déclarent mais génère beaucoup de cash
parce qu'évidemment c'est du cash et de
cela j'ai envie de dire la criminalité
chinoise a dû apprendre à gérer ce cach
et qu'est-ce qu'on en fait d'abord pour
le renvoyer au pays pour payer les
factures de ceux qui livrent et et aussi
pour des investissements locaux pour
profiter de l'argent local et donc ce
sont développés des circuits de
banchimement et nous ce qu'on au parquet
de Paris ce qu'on avait à connaître et
et et ce dont on a saisit nous et cejf
maintenant c'est ce qu'on appelle des
des manquements aux obligations
déclaratives c'est des véhicules qui
sont chargés de de cash 200 300 500000 1
million d'euros qui partent
d'aubervillier et qui vont vers le nord
de la France et pour se diriger ensuite
plutôt vers des pays à l'est de chez
nous hein la Hongrie la Pologne où la
bancarisation se fait dans des
conditions plus simples moins exigeantes
euh on demande pas forcément des
justificatifs pour ensuite une fois que
c'est bancarisé dans ces pays se cach et
bien ça rejoint enfin ça part très vite
comme vous savez save on a déjà vous le
dire vers Hong Kong vers ces pays qui
sont pas coopérants donc nous on a connu
comme ça d'abord ce phénomène
d'aubervillier donc du Sifa avec
des des places qui sont en réseau hein
on a la même place en Italie plateau on
a la même place en Espagne on a donc
c'est c'est un système qui est tout à
fait européen qui justifie d'ailleurs
qu'on fasse beaucoup aussi de manquement
aux obligations déclaratives entre
l'Espagne et l'Italie les douaniers
contrôlent beaucoup de véhicules de
camion qui sont chargés ou de marchandis
pas déclaré ou au retour de véhicules
qui sont chargés d'argent qui vont qui
vont comme ça payer les fournisseurs et
qui vont rejoindre le circuit dont je
parlais donc cette communauté a acquis
une vraie compétence en matière de
blanchiment bah qu'il metent à
aujourd'hui à la disposition de ceux qui
veulent bien en user donc c'était au
départ uniquement peut-être pour le
textile aujourd'hui ça c'est une offre
une prestation de blanchiment qu'on
offre à à des gens qui qui font du
travail illégal qui font la fraudte
fiscale ou du trafic de stup c'est un
dossier que Paris on a dû peut-être vous
en parler parce que c'est les deux
dossiers qu'on fait qu'a fait très bien
le cerge DDF en son temps dossier euh
virus et rétrovirus où on a retrouvé en
même temps des dans un même dossier ce
qui pisait pas au second on trouvait des
trafiquants de stupéfiants avec des
fraudurs fiscaux euh ça plaisait moins
au second qu'au premier mais mais c'est
vrai que c'était c'est un phénomène
qu'on connaît assez bien de blanchiment
et c'est une vraie prestation de de
qualité vois je dire et et pour ça que
j'avais dit qui est connu de de ceux qui
cherchent à blanchir euh ce type d'opé
enfin les opérations
frauduleuses et les Chinois offrent
offrent ce type de service mais sont pas
des seuls
évidemment dans cet article c'est que il
y a des systèmes de blanchiment et qui
sont liés les les uns aux autres sur des
activités qui sont des activités
distinctes c'est des entreprises
spécialisées dans le blanchiment qui
peuvent tout blanchir quelle que soit
l'origine des
fonds tout à fait tout à fait
c'est-à-dire que si on avait pu enfin je
à l'époque j'étais plutôt concentré sur
je dirais il il y a 25 ans ou 20 ans je
travaillais plus sur le la criminalité
organisée classique et je m'intéressais
moins à l'argent et là aussi on a changé
un peu la façon d'appréhender ce type de
criminalité on la considère plus sous
son aspect produit d'infraction circuit
financier blanchiment euh chacun se
débrouiller un peu de son côté pour
essayer de blanchir son activité mais
aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate c'est que
les circuits blanch ent mettre au pot
commun l'argent c'estàd quel que soit
pour le coup l'argent n'a pas d'odeur
l'argent n'a pas d'odeur c'est l'argent
il est il est blanchi quel que soit le
délit ou ou le crime initial par des
organisations qui vont offrir des
prestations qui nécessitent un vrai
savoir-faire c'est-à-dire que souvent il
faut avoir des sociétés fictives il faut
avoir des comptes bancaires qui sont
volatiles ou ou difficilement traçables
il faut avoir des numéros de téléphone
des des qu'on lorsqu'on va déclarer à la
banque son son son compte il faut avoir
des des adresses mail tout ça ce sont
des prestations des véritables
prestations offertes aujourd'hui par
différentes personnes et quel que soit
euh le l'infraction d'origine et et il
en va de même pour le les les trafics de
de de d'argent enfin le blanchiment du
du stup même si je ne dis pas que cela a
totalement remplacé les phénomènes
nawala qu'on connaissait classique de
compensation classique qui existe
toujours en matière de
stupéfiant vous avez cette fois dans
journal Le
Monde
on est des grands lecteurs au sein de
notre commission vous avez parlé de la
présomption de blanchiment c'est un
outil qui est particulièrement efficace
et vous posez la question de savoir
jusqu'où vous pourrez aller dans
l'utilisation de cette présomption de
blanchiment et vous terminez au regarde
de la criminalité organisée telle qu'on
la connaît on est encore très loin de
pouvoir atteindre véritablement les
chefs de réseau et donc c'est un outil
efficace mais il n pas suffisamment
efficace pour atteindre des têtes de
réseau c'est un petit peu comme ça qu'on
interprète cet article du Monde
euh c'est un outil très efficace pardon
un outil typiquement français alors je
j'ai pas faiting suffisamment pour vous
dire si c'est vraiment mais en tout cas
lorsqu'on en parle avec nos collègues
étrangers ils sont ils nous regardent
avec les yeux très très envieux qui qui
brillent en disant vous avez vraiment un
outil très efficace c'est un outil dont
l'efficacité aussi dépend je dois le
dire de la portée qu'entendra et que qu'
jusqu'à présent entendu lui donner la
Cour de cassation c'està dire que
jusqu'à présent on a quand même une
chambre criminelle de la Cour de
cassation qui donne une interprétation
très large très efficace à cet article à
cette présempption mais voilà en état je
dois faire le constat que c'est
extrêmement efficace vous savez c'est
tout simplement le renversement de la
charge de la preuve il suffit qu'il y un
acte de dissimulation pour qu'on
considère que s'il y a pas de
justification économique flagrante
l'acte de dissimulation non pas
constitue la culpabilité mais oblige la
personne qui a S livré à cette opération
au départ c'était tout simple on a
utilisé pour ces voitures remplies de
cach sortant de du Sifa voilà il est
assez peu naturel enfin moi je le fais
pas de me promener avec un million
d'euros B je les ai pas vous imaginez
bien en espèce caché dans les ailes de
de mon véhicule ou sous le fauteuil ou
donc ça c'est l'acte de
simulation la justification économique
l'explication c'estelle est pas donné
aussitôt bien mod c'est man obligations
décaratif vous savez franchissement fr
c'est au-delà de 10000 € vous devez
déclarer que vous auprès des douanes que
vous déclarez que vous transportez 10000
€ donc vous avez ce manquement
déclaratif qui en soit constitue déjà un
Act de dissimulation la voiture la
planque donc ça renverse la chasse de la
preuve Si vous ne êtes si vous n'êtes
pas en capable en capacité de me dire
d'où vient cet argent je considère que
vous vous faites une opération de
blanchiment ça veut dire je n'ai pas à
démontrer quelle est l'infraction
d'origine ce qui est le cas pour le
blanchiment lorsque je veux vous faire
condamner du chef de blanchiment il faut
que je démontre que l'argent que vous
possédez et bien c'est de l'argent qui
provient d'une activité criminelle ouou
délictueuse donc c'est à moi de prouver
d'où ça vient et c'est à moi de prouver
que là d'où ça vient c'est une activité
illégale où ça va plus loin et et et où
il y a des limites on a vu sur des
dossiers notamment
euh comment dire les choses mettant en
cause des oligarques d'un pays en guerre
actuellement euh dont nous sommes des
dossiers dont nousous sommes saisis
parce que vous avez quelquefois
l'utilisation de sociétés en empilement
de sociétés à l'étranger avec des trust
mais qui quelquefois cette obligationf
cette dissimulation apparente en tout
cas ou cette complexification du schéma
de financement peut très bien aussi ne
pas répondre à une volonté de dissimuler
l'origine frauduleuse des fonds ça peut
répondre aussi à une logique économique
complexe à une optimisation fiscale qui
n'est pas une fraude fiscale ou à
volonté de se dissimuler aussi peut-être
des dirigeants d'un pays qui ne vous
veut pas forcément que la sympathie donc
là c'est c'est assez complexe parce que
quand on n pas le pays qui d'origine qui
collabore
ou qui ou la personne qui est mise en
cause qui ne collabore pas c'est
jusqu'où là à partir de quand doit-on
considérer que la dissimulation est en
soit un élément de de de preuve qui nous
permet de basculer vers le la
présomption de blanchiment ça c'est un
sujet autre thématique sur laquelle on a
travaillé et qu'on travaille qu'on porte
pour le coup j'ai envie de dire au SJF
c'est le blanchimement via les
cryptoactifs c'est-à-dire que
l'utilisation des cryptoactifs n'est pas
en soi euh signifiant d'une volonté de
dissimulation aujourd'hui tout le monde
a des enfin tout le monde mon adjin par
exemple pas moi euh à des à des
cryptoactifs mais c'est pas en soit une
une activité illégale et c'est c'est pas
une activité d'imulation en revanche euh
on peut être nous informé par un service
étranger de ce qu'ils ont identifié sur
une plateforme étrangère un portefeuille
dont ils sont capables de nous dire
qu'il est détenu par un résident
français euh et dont les fonds avant
d'arriver sur ce portefeuille sont
passés par ce qu'on appelle un mixeur
alors mixeur c'est une sorte de
plateforme une là aussi une prestation
qu'on va vous offrir c'est une sorte de
grosse boule dans le qu on va dans
laquelle on va mettre vos cryptoactifs
qui vont être mélangé à d' crypto
d'autres cryptoactifs et normalement à
la sortie on n plus capable de dire si
c'est é v cryptoctif à l'entrée ou pas
donc ça ça ça rond cette fameuse
blockchain vous savez et donc ça c'est
un acte de nous on considère que c'est
un acte de dissimulation parce qu'il n'a
pas de logique économique et surtout
c'est facturé c'est facturé entre 20 ou
30 % de la montant du montant des des
des sommes qui passent par ces par ces
mixeurs donc accepter de sacrifier 20 ou
30 % du capital sans logique économique
on considère nous nous considérons que
c'est un acte de dissimulation qui peut
faire présumer euh et donc pour nous
pour le coup c'est extrêmement
confortable parce que on saisit des
cryptoactifs on a saisi plusieurs
dizaines de millions de cryptoactif
comme ça sur des
plateformes grâce à cette présemption
sans laquelle nous aurions été démunis
ou sans laquelle n nousons pas pu
démontrer l'origine frauduleuse des
sommes sur ces
portefeuilles deux questions pour ma
part euh sans préjudice des questions
qui viendront de chez de mes collègues
euh
la corruption est un des phénomènes
qu'on nous a plus fréquemment évoqué là
des auditions précédentes dans dans les
enquêtes du du sejf est-ce que vous avez
déjà croisé ou constaté des des faits de
corruption qui qui ont d'agents publics
notamment qui ont pu faciliter la mise
en place de circuits de blanchiment de
flux financiers l au narcotrafic
première question et puis une deuxième
question qui est plus personnelle qui
tient votre parcours personnel vous êtes
passé vous l'avez rappelé par
plusieurs fonctions et responsabilités
qui vous ont mis au
contact de de du trafic des narcotrafic
ce soit à Marseille à Paris est-ce que
quelles sont les dynamiques que vous
observez sur ce jeallais pas dire sur ce
temps long parce que ce serait
inconvenant ou désagréable mais sur ces
quelques
années Président je vous remercie je je
vais sous réserve de de confirmation
d'affirmation de de de mes
collaborateurs
euh non la corruption c'est pas un
phénomène que que nous détectons d'une
manière particulièrement forte même
minime d'ailleurs au service on na pas
constaté de fa de corruption de
phénomène de corruption majeur ou ou
même mineur au service c'est c'est pas
quelque chose qui à mes yeux est
important c'est un phénomène qu'on
connaît qu'on appréhende qu'on a bien en
en visé parce que pour échanger par
exemple avec nos nos collègues des
Pays-Bas du fiod qui est le service
équivalent de la dnrod du SGF un peu
voilà pour pour dire des choses au
Pays-Bas on s on est all je suis allé
les voir ils sont dû nous voir eux sont
sont dramatiquement sont enfin considère
que chez eux la c'est une situation ce
point catastrophique qui la considère
même presque perdue parce que il y a une
telle corruption chez eux que il ne sait
plus trop comment mon mon homologue
traittit traiter la chose euh pour pour
ce qui est de notre part c'est c'est on
rencontre pas ce phénomène dans les
enquêtes que nous traitons voilà donc je
pourrais pas vous en parler utilement et
pour le coup dans le la création de l'
naaf on s'est bien réparti les les
choses aussi avec le cliff euh vous
savez qu' le cliff qui est l'office en
charge spécialement des faits de
d'attete à la probabilité si tenté et ça
peut nous arriver que nous percevions ou
que nous ayons un doute sur un phénomène
de corruption nous en rendons compte au
magistr amendant et en l'invitant
peut-être à saisir le cliff pour qu'il
traite de de ces matières puisque moi je
je ne suis pas compétent au sens légal
du terme pour traiter de des phénomènes
de corruption je pourrais traiter en
infraction connexe mais c'est pas c'est
pas mon sujet voil sur la dynamique qui
peut animer le
narcotrafic jefin comment dire les
choses je suis heureux quand on gagne
des batailles voilà je suis heureux
quand on gagne des bataill je depuis 40
ans depuis 30 ans que je mène une guerre
j'ai pas l'impression que on est
beaucoup gagné qu'on a gagne un peu plus
chaque jour
euh le le
principal la principale évolution a été
je pense que Stéphanie charbonniier vous
en av peut-être parlé à lofast
parce que on travaille longtemps en
partenariat moi magistrat et elle comme
comme comme enquêtrice et dans
différents services à
cherfofastrice ce qui a ces dernières
années révolutionné notre appréhension
de de ces de ce phénomène c'est quand
même les dossiers encrochat
CICC sont vraiment des dossiers qui nous
ont bousculé euh parce que la vision que
nous avions de ces trafics était
peut-être très ne correspondait
peut-être pas à la réalité telle qu'elle
existait depuis longtemps déjà c'estàd C
cette cet aspect très international du
trafic bon international bien sûr tout
le monde savait que on fabrique pas la
cocaïne en France he qui le mais c'est
un monde d'affaires un monde où la
rentabilité le le coût
la
productivité sont des des éléments qui
sont aujourd'hui comme n'importe quelle
autre affaire discutter entre les gens
qui achètent et qui vendent ce qu'on a
vu au travers des conversations ceicc
c'est cette capacité à vendre du produit
à se racheter pour le revendre ensuite
c'est un vrai commerce international où
le coût de fabrication présente rien en
réalité vous savez fabriquer une tonne
de coque en Colombie ça coûte rien ce
qui coûte c'est le transport c'est le
fait de pouvoir la livrer
jusqu'au jusqu'au cons consommateur donc
c'est là où tout l'enjeu existe donc une
massification de de de ces échanges
l'internationalisation de ce commerce et
pour le coup je reprendrai ce que m'a
dit un voyou Corse une fois que je
mettais en examen avant de d'écrouer un
très très gros voyou non enfin je v pas
dire Corse un voyou sur sur sur
Marseille qui qui me
disait monsieur monsieur monsieur le
juge moi je travaille plus ici en France
ENF parce que parce qu'ici on peut plus
travailler je veux dire en cela qu'il
faut pas non plus être trop pessimiste
on a une législation française qui est
très efficace sur le territoire national
on a une obligation dénonciation de
révélation par les différents acteurs du
secteur économique qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui pour les les flux
manifestement illégaux ou trop
visiblement illégaux sont quand même
bien dénoncés traités tracf on travaille
en très grand partenariat avec Tracfin
euh sont sont des systèmes qui
aujourd'hui amènent ces gens-là à être
comme vous le savez à Dubaï ou ailleurs
mais très peu en France en réalité c'est
que les effets de leur commerce se font
sentir chez nous et les effets les plus
désastreux c'est ce qui se passe à
Marseille dans les cités où des pauvres
gosses des des Minos se tirent dessus et
meurent à longueur de journée c'est ça
les effets visibles chez nous mais ceux
qui commandent ils sont pas basés ils
sont pas à Marseille enfin t que je
puisse savoir ou à Paris ou
ils sont des exécutantsin qui sont
majoritairement les commanditaires sont
ailleurs et skcc nous a vraiment révélé
ça j'ai l'habitude de dire que jusqu'à
présent on avait une hauteur du de vue
du trafic qui était à hauteur de Tonton
pardonnez-moi expression c'est
d'avviseur d'informateur parce que
l'informateur il connaît son N+1 voir
son N+ 2 mais il connait rarement
audessus enfin l'informateur pas trop
actif on ceux qui sa
mais on s'estaperçu qu'il y avait un
échelon supérieur qui était plutôt basé
à à
l'étranger alors j'ai Franck Ménonville
Olivier Cadic et Marie
Carlotti merci
président d'accord sauf si notre
collègue sauf si notre collègue
Carlotti sauf si notre collègue Carlotti
doit partir pour une autre Fran non
non allezy chers collègue monsieur le
juge excusez-moi mais je dois
partir pour intervenir en séance oui sur
le blanchiment des narcotrafiquants
finalement est-ce qu'ils utilisent pas
les mêmes stratégies financières que les
grosses entreprises multinationales sauf
que leurs produits sont illégaux ou
est-ce qu'ils mettent en place des
systèmes tout à fait particulier voyez
ce que est-ce qu'ils ont les mêmes
circuits les mêmes réseaux bon
évidemment je fais la différence hein
l'activité n'est pas la même et
l'activité criminelle voilà ça c'est ma
première question et la deuxième je sais
que vous être attaché aux douanes mais
vous me dites que bientôt vous allez
diriger l'Office national c'est la
mutation de lutte contre les fraudes aux
finances publiques c'est ça est-ce que
du coup vous allez vous occuper ou
est-ce que vous vous occupez déjà du
blanchiment qui se passe sur notre
territoire je pensais au golf aux hôtels
au magasins de luxe et cetera est-ce que
ça fait partie de votre compétence ou
est-ce que où est-ce que non qui s'en
occupe je vous remercie madame la
sénatrice ça servit vous savez dans dans
les
interrogatoires euh
h je vous promets nous sommes attachés
au douan je passer la deème
question nous restons ce que nous sommes
c'est-à-dire que le changement de nom ne
change pas le fait que nous sommes
rattachés aux douanes et aux finances
publiques donc bien évidemment nous
traitons du blanchiment sous toutes ces
formes sur le territoire
national
et le blanchiment représente 40 % de
l'activ de notcti à peu près ouais 40
donc nous traitons 40 % de dos dossier
de blanchiment en réalité qui n'est pas
du blanchiment nécessairement douignier
c'est du blanchiment commis sur le
territoire national mais plutôt de ce
qu'on appelle dans les langage langage
judiciaire du haut du spectre donc les
affaires complexes donc ça peut traiter
évidemment de tout et nous traitons du
blanchiment commis par ou au sein de
multinationales voilà je je viens vous
le dire le secret d'instruction
d'enquête m'interdit de vous de de de
vous répondre plus avant mais nous
traitons
d'affaires de de blanchiment commises
par des grandes soci
sur la démarche j'ai envie je je alors
évidemment on appréende pas du tout la
même façon blanchiment commis par des
trafiquants de stupéfiant d'ailleurs on
nintervient que deun manière très
marginale je pourrais peut-être vous en
dire un mot ça parce que on regarde ce
qui est votre objet nous n'intervenons
que d'une manière très marginale sur le
narcotrafic enfin le blanchiment du
narcotrafic nous prenons pas de la même
façon blanchiment commis par une société
multinationale même si les mécanismes se
ressemblent endroit c'est la même
chose et puis mais ce qui c'est
intéressant si vous c'est que en fait
vous apercevez que les les les
organisations criminelles ou ou les
voyou à titre personnel à un moment on
ont pour objectif de légaliser et
donc leur objet finalement c'est de
devenir des chefs d'entreprise en
réalité et et le point de le point de
difficulté pour nous c'est lorsqu'ils
ont des activités légales qui deviennent
au moins aussi important si ce n'est
plus importante que leurs activités
illégal là ça devient très très surtout
s'ils sont basés à l'étranger ça devient
très très très très difficile pour nous
de faire le départ dans leurs activités
entre ce qui est légal de ce qui ne
l'est pas pour justifier l'origine des
fonds et là je connais certaines
organisations qui ont prospéré ou
certains acteurs j'ai travaillis 15 ans
dans le sud-estz pas je je les acteurs
que je connais sont plutôt dans le
sud-est euh sont sont ont si bien réussi
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont des activités qui
sont devenues pour l'essentiel des
activités légales euh donc c'est c'est
c'est c'est de cela dont il s'agit en
réalité sur le narcotrafique peut-être
sur sur le blanchiment pour vous
indiquer qu'effectivement à la création
de ce
service il n pas été souhaité par le
ministère de l'Intérieur donc il y a 20
ans de cela que nous allions travailler
sur le blanchiment de trafic de de
stupéfiants ou sur les stupéfiants
c'était pourtant la volonté du service
des doines vous imaginez la
dneurod non donc en fait le sejf ne peut
être saisi du trafic de stupéfiant ou du
blanchiment de trafic de stupéfiant
qu'en cosaisine c'està dire avec un
autre service euh donc n nous avons en
portefeuille enfin de depuis on a fait
recensé depuis 3 ans là on a 36 dossiers
de de blanchiment de trafi de trafic de
stupéfiants euh avec des intensités très
très différentes ça peut être à
l'origine un manquement aux obligations
déclaratives c'estàdire un contrôle qui
va se faire on va découvrir 100 enfin 00
100000 200000 € d'argent le chien des
douanes va marquer stup et là ça oriente
blanchiment stup donc le service de le
parquet va être obligé de nous caisir
avec un autre service de de de police ou
de gendarmerie pour travailler sur ce
sujet parce que nous pouvons pas
travailler seul en revanche nous avons
six dossiers avec l'ofast en en
cosaisine des dossiers pour le coup très
intéressants
euh où on a un vrai travail de de nous
de notre côté o vraiment en plus il y a
pas de difficulté parce que travaille
sur les trafiquants de stupéfiants et
sur le produit nous on travaille sur
vraiment l'autre l'autre versant le
blanchiment et avec nos compétences
réleectives nous l'apport qu'on peut
apporter aussi en cryptoonnaie depuis
que je suis arrivé moi j'ai demander aux
services de de se former aux
cryptomonnaaies on découvre des
cryptomonnaaies dans pratiquement toutes
nos perquisitions maintenant c'est c'est
très symptomatique hein c'est demain je
pense que le commerce se fera d'ailleurs
ubersheit se sera livré et payé avec un
Wallet en crypto donc on a on a on a
vraiment une collaboration très efficace
et avec Stéphanie charbonnier vraiment
s'en réjouit tous les jours les odj
aussi travaillent vraiment les ofj avec
les les OPJ classiques de l'oface très
très bien et je crois qu'on apporte on
apporte notre savoir sur cette sur ce
sujet je pourrais vous parler d'un
dossier qui était très illustrant où on
me posait la question sur les finances
public et le narcotrafic hein je crois
on a un dossier qui part d'un escerie au
chômage partiel sur lequel nous
travaillons aussi 200000 € d'une société
effictive qui demandait le paiement qui
avait obtenu le paiement de 200000 € de
de salaire
euh c'est dénoncé par la Direction
départementale des finances publiques de
je sais plus quel département ça va ça
finit au Parquet de Nice le Parquet de
Nice nous saisit mais avec peu d'espoir
puisque tout le monde avait compris que
la société qui avait bénéficié de ces
200000 € n'existait pas et que c'était
un gérant fictif donc système qu'on
connaît alors pour le coup très très
bien depuis 20 ans nous c'est c'est
détournement d'argent public par des des
individus qui savent comment il faut
faire mais en travaillant sur cette
société vraiment en travaillant sur
cette société en en croisant les les
numéros de compte les numéros de
téléphone les les adresses mail et tout
cela on a identifié toute une structure
de sociétés fictiv mais véritablement
des dizaines des dizaines de sociétés
fictives géré par un individu basé à
Dubaï qui met Un franco-marocain qui qui
met ses sociétés à disposition de toutes
les organisations criminelles qui le
souhaitent ça revient à ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure et on a remonté
comme
ça l'importation par celui donc qui
avait offert cette société à ceux qui
avaient bénéficié des 200000 € d'aide au
chômage partiel on avait remonté ces
sociétés avaient servi à importer de la
cocaïne bien évidemment dans des qutités
qu'on ignore mais notamment 600 kilo qui
avait été saisi au départ d'un Daport en
Amérique du Sud 10 tonnes de tabac à
envers encore il y a on a poursuivi 200
kg de fois 200 kg de méthamphétamine en
Allemagne imporé grâce à toutes ces ces
sociétés mises à
disposition par cet individu qui
a qui était franco-marocain basé à Dubaï
on a travaillé avec l'oface parce qu'on
a vu qu' arrivrivé 22 tonnes de sucre
grâce à ces sociétés on a compris que on
a senti faire du douignier pour le coup
qu' y avait 20 DESS qui était pas que du
sucre
dans un container contaminé à la cocaïne
en fait et en travaillant avec le Fast
sur cette cette importation on a
arrêté les les gens du cartel colombien
qui étaient venus à Barcelone avec leur
chimiste le numéro 2 du cartel de
nordest qui était on l'
arrêté Barcelone on a fait arrêter par
les autorités dubaot le commanditaire à
à Dubaï et ainsi que toute la jistique
française et ça s'est pas arrêté là
parce que les collègues du service
étaient à à bogotaille y a un mois et en
collaboration avec laadea le reste du
cartel du Nord-Est a été interpellé par
les américains ils sont en voie
d'extradition à destination des an tout
ça est parti d'une dénonciation sur du
chômage
partiel par Direction départementale des
finances publiques et notre saisine du
service voilà très intéressant comme
exemple Fran Menville que j'ai frustré
tout à l'heure non pas du tout merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur vous évoqueiez les la bonne
coopération in national ma question en
fait notamment quand vous évoquez
le certains pays
qui sont en mesure de plus facilement au
travers leur système bancaire de
bancariser des sommes importantes en
liquide ma question porte sur les les
partenariats et peut-être les
améliorations qui seraient nécessaires
au niveau
européen je ne peux à ma place que les
appeler de de mes vœux hein je pense que
là ça ça échappe à mes compétences mais
bien évidemment nous nous souitorions
que les obligations de de connaî ton
client pour parler français hein quoi
ici qui s'implique sur le territoire
national devrait être du même niveau au
moins au sein de l'Union européenne pour
éviter cette bancarisation dans des pays
d'union qui se fait dans des conditions
extrêmement extrêmement faciles beaucoup
plus facile que chez nous ça pas
empêcher moi j'ai j'ai suivi
au parquet de Paris un dossier qui nous
avait amené à poursuivre la banque of
China alors c'était assez improbable je
pourrais pas tout dire parce que comme
voilà on sort de cette enceinte
possiblement mais on avait obtenu une
CIP une convention d'intér judiciaire
public avec la banque of Chana parce
qu'on avait considéré qu'elle ne
respectait pas les obligations de
vérification qui étaient les siennes
justement à la suite de blanchiment qui
provenait du Sifa d'aubervillier et on
avait une information judiciaire et je
pense que China à la suite des
discussions qu'on a pu avoir avec eux
ils ont accepté de payer une une c'est
une amende dans le cadre d'une
convention d'int judiciaire donc on a
des moyens d'action sur ces banqu malgré
tout judiciaire mais ça serait en sens
plus simple effectivement si les règles
qui nous sont appliquées sur le
territoire national et qui ont justifié
cette appréciation de de ce malfaiteur
marseillais sur la capacité qu'il avait
désormais à travailler sur le territoire
national si ça pouvait s'étendre au sein
de l'Union européenne ça serait bien
Olivier galiic
oui merci ça va un peu aller dans dans
complément de ce que vient de d'évoquer
mon mon collègue j'étais à Panama il y a
pas très longtemps et justement il y a
bah tout un un enjeu puisque c'est un
pays de transit des stupéfiants et le
donc ils sont conscients de la
problématique et puis les autorités font
justement de la lutte contre le crime
organisé une priorité et
on on avait parlé donc de la de
disposition législative pour connaître
les bénéficiures finaux bénéficiaires
finaux des entreprises vous savez que je
crois qu'il y a une quarantaine de
cabinet d'avocats qui gèent à peu près
150000 sociétés donc on peut imaginer la
problématique pour connaître le
bénéficiaire final de chacune de des
sociétés et cette problématique donc que
je vois c'est effectivement c'est qu'on
voit des États qui contournent les
sanctions qui utilisent ces réseaux il
faut bien contourner les sanctions
économiques donc ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent qui passe et que ces
systèmes se confondent évidemment donc
avec le trafic de drogue donc comment
vous justement vous appréhendez est-ce
que vous avez où est-ce qu'on en est sur
la liste al j'ai évoqué Panama sans les
accusés mais on pourrait parler d'autres
États où on parle souvent vous avez
mentionné Dubaï euh on pourrait parler
de Singapour de Hong Kong donc il y a un
certain nombre de places financières où
j'ai j'ai envie de dire que je peux pas
dire qu'elles sont qu'elles
s'accommodent mais certains
s'accommodent de ces placesl comment
donc vous envisagez-vous les enquêtes
dans dans ces cas-là
et par rapport à ces pays peu
coopératifs où est-ce qu'on en est où
est-ce que vous vous en êtes dans vos
enquêtes est-ce que vous arrivez
effectivement à faire la part des choses
eu et un des des vrais sujets pour nous
maintenant qui se pose et qui va se
poser à mon avis de plus en plus c'est
la présence maintenant de ce qu'on peut
qualifier de narco-état donc des États
qui ont pignon sur rue qui vont siège à
l'ONU qui viennent parler et qui
facilite le trafic de drogue y compris
ce sa financiérisation et donc est-ce
que vous voyez ce phénomène se
développer est-ce que il y a des états
qui vous posent aujourd'hui problème je
vous demanderai pas de les citer là mais
puisque c'est public mais mais vraiment
est-ce que ce problème commence à venir
parce que c'est un un sujet que l'on
voit puisque ce sont des gens qui
peuvent faire du lobbying à l'ONU et
donc ça nous pose aussi des problèmes
dans la réglementation si eux-mêm
essayent de bloquer des réglementations
internationales qui ne conviennent pas
au crime organisé donc j'aimerais avoir
votre avis là-dessus euh je vous
remercie monsieur le sénateur je je pour
le coup je je n'ai pas d'avis euh j'ai
un avis mais un titre personnel mais qui
ne vaut pas euh Ren homnes je pense que
Stéphanie charbony aura peut-être plus
de compétences pour vous dire cela euh
donc je préfère ne pas m'avancer pour
nous concrètement ça se traduit par une
non réponse aux questions que l'on pose
donc ça peut effectivement mettre fin à
une enquête parce que on va adresser une
demande d'entraide ou plus directctement
une commission rugatoire par exemple on
sait qu'à Hong Kong aujourd'hui ils ne
répondent plus c'est Hong Kong ne répond
plus à nos demandes donc c'est c'est
très concret voilà donc c'est je fais
pas je fais pas de politique en disant
cela je dis que concrètement quand on
une adresse à Hong Kong une demande une
commission ratoire internationale et
bien on a aucune réponse alors que il y
a encore peu de temps on avait on avait
des réponses inversement je pense que le
rôle joué par le Gaffi aussi n'est pas
totalement étranger à certaines choses
je pense que je pense positivement il y
a des pays du côté de Dubaï des éirat
Arab Unis qui sont soumis pour l'instant
je crois ou qui ont été soumis à à un
examen du Gaffi on a eu un peu plus de
réponse ponctuellement à certaines des
questions ou des des des demandes
d'entraide que l'on a adressé à ces pays
donc que tout cela nous dépasse hein
c'est c'est
des c'est des relations internationales
la politique qui nous on fait le constat
queeectivement on nous répond nous
répond pas donc voà par contre ça nous
empêche pas que lorsqu'on va
percussionner chez un individu je pense
à un gros frur fiscal et que on a des
échanges dans son téléphone ou dans son
ordinateur où on voit qu'il répond à des
mails sur des sujets qui traitent de
transfert d'argent à destination d'un
Kong à Hong Kong on peut l'interroger
sur l'origine en tout cas la cause de
ces mails et la justification et de ce
pourquoi il aurait un compte à Hong Kong
et à partir de là on retombe sur ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure sur les
éléments qui nous permettent de
considérer qu'on a peut-être des des
sommes qui sont dissimulées à l'étranger
qui peuvent caractériser une
présempption de manchiment donc
l'utilité de ce
texte Étienne blanc oui pour prendre un
un exemple très très concret et vos
services ont participés avec le
commandement de la gendarmerie dans le S
esace à la fermeture d'un trafic de
stupéfiant alors c'est assez particulier
il utilisait un sononyme
explicite drog source est-ce que vous
pouvez n expliquer comment vous avez été
saisi par qui vous avez été saisi et
puis ensuite quels sont les moyens
d'investigation que vous avez pu mettre
en
place pour mettre un terme à ses
activités parce que
sur les
cryptonnaie on est sur un sujet
techniquement très compliqué est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire quels sont les
moyen dont vous disposez pour traquer ce
genre de finance
occulte alors Monsieur rapporteur je
suis désolé je pourrais pas trop même
pas du tout vous parler de drog source
puisque c'est un dossier qui n'est pas
jugé qui est toujours à l'enquête euh
donc c'est un sujet qui peut que dont je
ne peux pas parler je peux simplement
vous indiquer que c'est un dossier qui a
été dénoncé par par la douane et par un
service pour le coup et je je le dis je
rappelle moi je je suis pas douanier je
suis pas j'ai aucun intérêt dans la
douane et mais un service qui un service
d'élite au sein Douine qui est assez peu
connu et c'est dommage s'appelle
cyberdine où sont des gens de très
grande qualité qui vont chasser sur le
Darknet et qui vont chasser les les
délinquants sur le Darknet et notamment
les trafiquants de stup donc ils ont
découvert ca et on a des sujets communs
encore même pour tout vous dire actuell
de manière très très présente sur unorme
dossiers qu'on pourrait récupérer avec
eux euh le le darkneck qui offre cet
anonyma que vous savez que vous
connaissez et qui permet de vendre
toutes sortes de choses des stupéfiants
des armes des médicaments et j'ai envie
de dire aussi des sites pédopornoau et
tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer tous
les paiements sur le Darknet se font en
en cryptoonnaie
donc ma sensibilisation à cette
problématique elle date de de mes
anciennes fonctions où je où j'ai j'ai
compris qu'il fallait si on voulait
aussi lutter avec efficacité contre
cette criminalité éminemment
internationale et bien aller sur sur le
Dark non seulement sur Dark mais aussi
récupérer l'argent sur le sur le
cyber on a des outils j'ai envie de vous
dire on a des outils qu'on achète ça
coûte cher des formations qu'il faut
donner une sensibilisation qu'il faut
apporter à l'ensemble des agents mais on
y arrive et et on y arrive à ce point
que les on est les autres services de
police judiciaire
nous sollicite ou demande au magistrats
que l'on soit coaisi avec eux pour
travailler plus spécifiquement sur la
blockchain sur l'identification des
avoirs et sur la saisie des avoirs parce
que contrairement à ce qu'on dit je suis
pas un grand spécialiste je vais pas
vous faire un grand cours sur la sur la
blockchain mais j'ai des gens chez moi
qui le qui le font très bien la
blockchain finalement on dit toujours on
dit que c'est compliqué mais une fois
que vous avez compris c'est c'est un peu
comme vous savez les téléphones
portables quand c'est arrivé moi j'étais
jeun jeune magistrat ça été la
catastrophe on s'est dit c'est fini ils
vont nous échapper on narrivait pas à
intercepter les les les téléphones
portables on pouvait mettre sur écout
que les téléphones fixes puis du jour on
a mis sur écout les téléphones portables
on avait gagné l'UTO parce qu'il se
méfiait pas et donc on entendait tout et
ben la blockchain c'est un peu ça j'ai
envie de dire passer cette ce temps de
de sidération quand vous savez
travailler sur la blxchain c'est
immodifiable et c'est traçable jusqu'à
l'infini et donc vous pouvez remonter
une fois que vous avez compris qui est
propriétaire de SW
ben vous pouvez remonter à l'infini et
donc d'où l'intérêt d'investir sur la
blockchain et on a investi sur la
blockchain et je crois avec succès en
tout cas c'est ce que nous disent les
magistrats et l'ensemble des autres
services de police et de gendarmerie qui
demandent à travailler avec nous même
les services c3n vous voyez par exemple
c'est assez signifiant parce que le c3n
c'est le service cyber de la gendarmerie
qui fait partie du COM cyber gendarme
c'est l'équivalent de l'Office
gendarmerie mais côté gendarmerie et ils
ont demander à être saisi avec nous
alors qu'ils ont toute la compétence
technique pour travailler sur la contre
la cyber mais sur le blanch
en utilisant les cryptoactifs on a cette
compétence tout à fait particulière qui
vient s'ajouter à celle d'autres
services lorsque cela est
nécessaire question quelle est la part
des des des affaires que vous ouvrez qui
proviennne
d'informateur alors pour ma part zéro
puisque je je je n'ai pas l'autosaisine
c'est une autre spécific vous savez
quand vous naissez petit
petit service à compétence nationale au
sein du ministère des Finances à côté du
gros ministère de l'intérieur on essaie
de limiter vos vos ch d'intervention on
l'a limité sur les stupes en disant vous
ne pourrez travailler qu'en caisine on
nous n'a pas donné non plus
l'autosaisine c'estd que je ne peux pas
me saisir d'un dossier un informateur on
a des informateurs qui pevent n dire des
choses on les renvoie vers les services
qui traitent les
informateurs donc moi je ne traite pas
les informateurs ou en tout cas si c'est
si si l'information qu'il donne mérite
traité on les renvoie vers des services
dans c'est le métier qui sont je
l'espère en tout cas formés pour
ça y a-t-il chez nos collègues d'autres
questions notre rapporteur semble
satisfait
comblé mais il me reste à vous
remercierci au nom de la commission de
votre présence des informations et puis
par avance pour l'écrit que vous nous
renverrez voilà merci
beaucoup